the New York Post reports Nancy Pelosi
booed in guest appearance at New York
City's Global citizen Music Festival I
think vote Tim the part that you're
missing is where they're about to change
the word the meaning of the word booze
that's right that's to me and it's
really really loved it everybody knows
boo means to show enthusiastic
so Nancy Pelosi comes out they were all
saying boo her Nancy Pelosi comes out on
stage and the the liberal stronghold of
New York City and The Crowd Goes Nuts
screaming the video is hilarious because
a guy's like it's Nancy Pelosi why is
everybody booing seriously
oh yeah but the best part was like you
can hear some of the women booing it's
very high pitched like Boo hilarious oh
and I'm like everyone is the boo you can
really hear the tones here yeah now this
is good news look it's because this
should be kind of a white pill in that
everybody hates Nancy Pelosi so at least
there's that like what if everything
ends with the left and the right holding
hands and singing about how much they
hate Chuck Schumer Pelosi Nadler yeah I
think that people really dislike
oligarchy and oligarchs in control of
our government it's not even who it's if
an oligarch gets in or someone gets in
there and then becomes an oligarch like
she's been well allegedly making all
sorts of money off stock trades I've
never seen the data to prove it but this
is what I've heard we don't want people
like I don't want people like that in
charge they're going to sell country she
makes better stocks trades than Warren
Buffett than anyone else in the world
how can you not see it it's like it's
like the right in front of my face it's
right in front of your face and and
seeing this video has honestly restored
my faith in humanity seeing it and and
then there's there's an amazing photo of
of her co-host that went up on stage
with her bill like hey here's Nancy and
Nancy's kind of standing there like holy
cow what did I just get myself into
getting a reality call as she's trying
to push a climate change agenda and then
everyone is just not having it so so
seeing this absolutely shows you that
that there is ABS they're huge huge huge
are you lowering my volume no what about
touching it unpopularly huge and I'm
distracted by the huge honest ginormous
unpopularity when it comes to the
current political establishment and it's
something that I think we need to focus
on and talk about more because the
reality probably is a lot different than
what we're getting on big Tech social
media that that manipulates the
algorithm here's here's what we'll do we
will we will uh create an event called
the we hate Nancy Pelosi Festival right
because you see hate you said hate was a
bad thing so yeah you guys are saying
but I'm saying right now if everyone in
the country hates Nancy Pelosi well then
it could be unifying right exactly we
could really all come together
where it's like a guy in a Maga hat and
a guy with like a pride flag and they're
yelling at each other and then it's like
oh you're nuts you support Nancy Pelosi
another guy goes what I hate Nancy
Pelosi and then the Trump guy goes you
hate Nancy Pelosi too yes I despise her
really me too really yeah what about her
don't you like oh she's a corporate show
I know
really let's sit down for a second and
they sit down and they're drinking
together and they're becoming best
friends and buddies for the rest of
their lives and they die old remember
her covert haircut
freezer packed with ice cream
it was unbelievable it was the capital
city of The Hunger yes everyone being
like my life is ruined and she's like
look at my 20 dollar Ice Cream you're
like no no I can't work 125. I can't pay
the bills she had entire freezer full I
know it's like packed she couldn't even
fit her like emergency Chicken in there
or whatever like a thousand dollars
worth of ice cream in her friends oh my
goodness that was so horrible and Biden
was like I love ice cream too
this is a the Democratic party
represents like it's a capital city and
then the corporate media Trump had two
scoops of ice cream he's bad right and
Biden's out there like with a dripping
off his chin I don't know do you think
term limits would solve it like flat out
solve this problem of oligarchs I don't
think so
the the issue isn't oligarchs the issue
is culture that people would vote for
Nancy Pelosi I know but like what are
they voting for actually just the name I
mean they might I mean yes to a certain
extent I mean people are used to
Outsourcing their political views to
whatever seems most expedient I don't
think they're voting for her I think
they're going and voting Democrat right
that's why I was saying a long time ago
remove Democrat republican from the from
the ballot so you don't know what party
they're a part of also first names just
initials so you can't tell who's who at
all what that would be interesting if
you have no idea who you're voting for
people go in and they go Democrat
Democrat democrat or republican
Republican Republican no if you don't
know who you're voting for don't vote
for them right that makes so remove the
party and just the names and then and
then you'll be looking at a bunch of
names and like I don't know but that's
what people do is they just like they
know they see the Democrat and even in
Pennsylvania they had a thing for a
while where you could just click
Democrat it'll give all you can pull the
lever you could just pull the I had a
politics teacher in high school uh Pat
reisnyder and she talked about that just
pull the lever yeah
the way at the top
I never voted in Pennsylvania I only
ever voted in New York so I say we
remove parties from the ballot so you'll
just see names what about for the
primary all well for the primary you
don't need to party on it anyway it's
the it's it's just like that should be
open I think do you think we've talked
about this before open primaries are
terrible I've been thinking about it
back and forth
yeah what is your thought uh I've been
wondering about it because in New York
I'm registered I'm a registered Democrat
so that I can vote in the primary that
has the most say over who ends up on the
final ballot
um but then I can't vote in the
Republican primary which would be where
I could vote for who I think should
probably actually be in charge well then
you should register as a republican yeah
but then you don't have a say in the
other side so it's kind of like the
problem is when Democrats and open
primaries sabotage or Republicans could
do the same thing so that's not a good
idea right so pull off the dndr term
limits two terms and we gotta have open
source voting machines because that's my
most demoralized issue
I can't stand like 10 term 85 year olds
that are like dripping I mean I would
say Ron two terms and out if I could get
the other three people supported term
limits so exactly he's a guy that would
give up the power out of righteousness
I think the issue with term limits is
you just create an industry that is a
shadow industry where people will form
committees to choose who's going to be
the next person they have to keep
picking and choosing somebody but but at
least the new person won't figure out
the swamp fast enough in order to of
course sell everyone down the river
except that they'll have all the
connections already preset but they
already have the connections then you
need term limits for staffers too you
need term limits for everybody turn
limits or FBI agents CIA agency work one
year you're out goodbye for about one
year no no no no no one year one month
this is absolutely insane the FBI should
be walked in the door they get a one
hour explanation for why what they do is
bad and then they're fired right away
exactly I like that
mine was kind of a a a one year well
yeah one year and then you get someone
new in there and then one year and you
get someone and then you're training you
figure it out they're all out when you
get hired as an IRS agent they walk you
in and you listen to a seminar on why
taxation is theft and then they fire you
yeah yeah absolutely no one will do this
I'm open to it I'm open to term limits
but I I really we need open source
voting machines I can't handle the the
private proprietary voting machines
anymore that's the most demoralizing
yeah that's crazy to think that I go in
and I cast my vote and then it goes to a
machine that it's tallied and private
and no one can see the code so you don't
know if it's actually tallying it
accurately like that just it tears me
down and makes me like not that I don't
want to vote but like I'm I'm I feel
hopeless did you vote in 2020. no you
didn't no no okay well then yeah I just
told people to vote for her
well I was going to say I wasn't
registered at the time I just moved so
vote so make sure you're registered now
vote in this election and then if it
turns out the place in which you vote
uses proprietary voting machines you can
file a lawsuit because you'll have
standing and you'll say I want to see
the code because for all I know it's a
random number generator
then you'll win someone's withstanding
just needs to do it so I guess if for
that matter I'm not a lawyer so I don't
necessarily know for sure but I'd
imagine if you did vote you should have
a right as a member of the public to see
the code to know how the machine works I
always told the story a long time ago to
Chicago where a guy I got a speeding
ticket
and he subpoenaed the code for the radar
gun and he told the judge for all I know
it's a random number generator he the
you have to prove it's interesting you
have to prove to the court it actually
tracks your speed and how it how it's
done and and the the company apparently
was like this is proprietary and you you
can't have it and they were like no it's
used in the public and it definitely
impact people's lives and so he actually
got it released then I think he had to
pay the ticket or something okay so it
wasn't random it was not a random number
generator no it actually works okay yep
uses radar you know bounces I always
check that when I'm like driving by
something it has your speed thing on it
and it's not always right
yeah but I mean I don't know where the
camera is or whatever but that's the
point right how do we know any of these
voting machines do what they say they do
unless the code is released to the
public so if you voted and you're
concerned just you file a lawsuit as per
the Public's right to know what these
machines do and how they do it it's
interesting because it you know having
it be proprietary and third party seems
messed up but also having an entire
government agency dedicated to creating
voting machines would seem messed up
so maybe we should just have paper
ballots and count them geez that's even
more I feel like that's even more messed
up everybody hands their box to a guy
who goes into a back room's like yeah
it's uh 74-31 they count them in they
count them in a yeah where Everyone's
Watching on camera yeah
I kind of like that how many is that
like ten thousand hours of footage that
no one no one person oh someone's gonna
watch it what do you think you're gonna
do just watch it like just live stream
it I mean watch it all over the world
like if someone's standing at a computer
and then there's 50 people behind them
and they made people stand far away to
watch too this last time right what was
it Arizona if they push a button on the
computer how do you know that they're
that they're doing it accurately you
don't exactly so it's like you know what
we're doing what they're doing they
write down the number and then hand the
sheet to to someone else well we're
coming up again
right I mean at a certain point we have
to be able to trust each other or have
trustless systems I think it's better
what is it what would a trust system
even look like it just really couldn't
gets pushed and then the tally happens
and you see all the math it's going to
be a lot easier for everyone just to
pick their their warlord and just to
have a suggestion box
exactly I'd like my I'd like my dictator
to know I want my character and then say
no next exactly and they'll be better
off probably than what we have right now
in my opinion well like with crypto I
can't like send you data and then you
don't get it like I you get it or I know
yeah it goes so like no they're talking
about they're talking about doing crypto
based voting in Africa and I think some
local jurisdictions have already
implemented it where everything is on
the blockchain people are able to see
the receipts people are able to see
everything coming back moving back and
forward and um that's that I was at a
African Bitcoin conference in Nigeria
that was actually implementing this in
local regions so there is a possibility
of implementing this kind of Open Source
free technology with all the receipts
all the transactions with the public
blockchain that I think would be worth
looking into uh but essentially with how
corrupted our political system of
suggestion boxes almost the same in my
opinion thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at
8pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there